and time reports Greek yogurt giant
Giovanni says there is no other option
but to take conspiracy theorists Alex
Jones to court a lawsuit filed in
federal court accuses Jones of making
false claims that linked Chobani to a
spike in tuberculosis and a sexual
assault case in Idaho last year that is
where the company operates the world's
largest yer Gert plant Don Dahler is
outside the Chobani cafe in New York
City with how the popular yogurt maker
became a target of right-wing media John
good morning good morning javonni says
those stories promoted by Alex Jones and
his website Infowars
have encouraged boycotts officials in
Idaho say Chobani had nothing to do with
these crimes but they still say that
Alex Jones and others deny that I'm
under massive sustained jawed attack
Infowars creator Alex Jones remains
defiant about claims he and his web site
made about Chobani and its founder
people he brought in and force-fed in
America have now been implicated
indicted and have pled guilty to that
Jones was responding to qu Bonnie's
lawsuit claiming this infowar segment is
full of lies so the report from the hill
said that Breitbart at the time had said
that this plant had brought not only
refugees but crime and tuberculosis
Jones sent the video to his more than
600,000 Twitter followers with the
provocative headline Idaho yogurt maker
caught importing migrant rapists Chobani
says in the complaint nowhere in the
video do the defendants state that the
plaintiff was caught importing migrant
rapists defendants knowingly
misrepresented the facts the story stems
from the sexual assault of a
five-year-old girl in Twin Falls Idaho
three boys from refugee families pled
guilty Shabani employs about 300
refugees in his twin falls factory posts
on info wars and other right-wing
website suggested the company had some
responsibility not one shred of fact to
that Mayor Shaun Berger says he's seen
nothing linking the crime to Joe Bonney
I certainly have heard some folks who
have said they're excited seed Chobani
make that effort
to correct the record head how you doing
Japanese founder Hamdi Ulukaya is from
Turkey and has been vocal on immigration
he spoke to 60 minutes steve Kroft
earlier this month one publication had a
headline that said american yogurt
tycoon vows to choke us with muslims
yeah thank you people targeted you yeah
it was a emotional emotional time people
you know hate you for doing something
right and what can you do about that
there's not much you can do
Jones claims President Trump is one of
his fans and during the campaign he
promoted another fictitious story about
the Democrats and Hillary Clinton
running a child sex ring out of a
Washington DC pizzeria but when faced
with the possibility of lawsuits Jones
retracted that and apologized we reached
out to Jones and his attorney but we
have not yet heard back for them Alex
John thanks